violent leftist protesters interrupted a
pro Trump straight Pride Parade in
Boston over the weekend leading to
dozens of arrests after they attacked
police officers then speaking of pride
parades Will & Grace stars Eric
McCormack and Debra Messing have called
for the public outing and blacklisting
of Trump supporters in Hollywood we
examine the animus against heterosexuals
and conservatives and we proudly
proclaim say it with me we're straight
we want to make America great get used
to it
Joe Biden gets caught in another major
lie on the campaign trail because it's a
day that ends in Y future also-ran bado
O'Rourke continues to humiliate himself
and we examine Democrats biggest
vulnerability going into 2020 all that
and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the straight Pride Parade actually
happened you remember during Pride Month
it used to be Pride Day and it was a
Pride Parade net then it was pride week
and now it's Pride Month pretty soon
it's gonna be pride all year long back
when that happened in June there were a
group of these kind of troll ish
conservative types who said they were
gonna host a straight Pride Parade in
Boston which is pretty hilarious and
they actually pulled it off
however the left was not happy about
this the left showed up in huge numbers
they totally outnumbered the guys
marching in the straight pride parade
and they got incredibly violent
they turned violent they started
attacking cops they a lot of them were
arrested I think about thirty six of
them were arrested so far this raises
the question though are they're not
straight leftists are they're not
homosexual conservatives of course there
are why is this a political matter why
did the straight pride parade become a
pro Trump parade well it was sort of
always that way what it shows you is
that LGBTQ alphabet pride and straight
pride are not really about sex at all
they're about politics you know during
Pride Month the June Pride Month I
talked about how awful pride is you know
only the left could take the deadliest
of the seven deadly sins the queen of
all vices to quote st. Gregory the Great
and turn it into the greatest virtue to
celebrate pride it's awful to celebrate
pride
you should never celebrate pride you
should try to replace all the pride that
you feel with humility which is the
beginning of virtue so if the straight
Pride Parade were actually about pride
then I would think it's just as bad as
the gay pride parade but it's not it's
about trolling it's about trolling the
actual pride parades and that's why it's
absolutely hilarious you know one of the
main photos from the Trump Pro Trump
straight pride parade is actually of a
man in a dress holding a big Pro Trump
sign
he's a transgender woman so he's a man
who identifies as a woman and he's there
at the straight
Pride Parade why what should he be at
the gay pride parade or the LGBT Pride
Parade no because the LGBT Pride Parade
is now all about leftism and it probably
always was and the straight Pride Parade
is all about conservatism and making fun
of pride parades in the first place you
got well the main photos is a guy in
drag and at the gay pride parade at this
point the vast vast majority of
attendees are actually straight leftists
who just want to signal how woke they
are so specifically I think what it gets
down to is that gay pride LGBTQ pride is
about tearing down the tradition up
ending the tradition it's not even
really about sex at all and the straight
Pride Parade is about defending
tradition that's why there wasn't a
whole lot of sexual imagery at the
straight Pride Parade it was a lot of
American flags and Magga hats and guys
who just like America and want to make
America great again
so of course it makes sense that antifa
and the radical left shows up to it here
is a group of anti Fateh esters drowning
out the straight pride demonstrators you
can't even hear the straight pride
demonstrators because an tifa's they're
screaming specifically chanting about
how much they like gay sex and hate
police officers
and there if you can't see it or if you
haven't seen this photo these are
anti-fog eyes wearing some like really
weird outfits some of them seem to be a
little bit in the kind of sadomasochism
Jean rather all carrying and Tifa flags
they just look like a bunch of weirdos
but the thing to notice about them is
there are many more of them than there
are so-called straight pride marchers so
what actually happened what does it mean
for the future of sexual politics and
politics generally we'll get to that in
a second but first as we see these crazy
demonstrators getting violent over the
weekend don't forget how important
safety is and rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer you already know
about their smart video doorbells and
cameras that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world
obviously safety really matters to me
people get very very violent these days
especially because of politics so if
you're in my line of work or if you're
listening to this right now you probably
have some strong political views things
are getting violent out there make sure
that you stay safe ring helps you be at
home even when you're not at home so you
could be in your bedroom you could be in
the office you could be on a beach
somewhere you could be circling the
world on the International Space Station
you know you could be anywhere and you
if you get a delivery for instance a
package delivery or a surprise visitor
you can get an alert you'll be able to
see here and speak to whoever's at the
door all from your phone so maybe it's
the nice delivery man maybe it's a bad
guy trying to rob you maybe it's your
mother-in-law maybe I don't even know
which is the worst of all those three
choices with ring you can know you can
make that decision that's thanks to the
HD video and two-way audio features on
ring devices and it just gives you peace
of mind you know for instance I have
this these friends that I gave a ring to
as a housewarming gift and they were
really nervous they thought someone was
like invading their house they thought
they had people creeping around at night
then they looked at their ring and they
realized it was a possum it was going
back and forth past the the door and if
it were me I'd probably go out there
with my gun and take care of the possum
but they're much nicer than I am
so now they may hear this they don't
wake up in a cold sweat they know
exactly
what they're getting it just gives you
peace of mind to know that you are safe
that you are protected as a listener you
have a special offer on a ring starter
kit available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
camp the starter kit has everything you
need to start building a ring of
security around your home go to ring.com
slash knowles kano wles that is ring.com
slash knoll scanner wles
so what actually happened at the
straight pride parade yet 200 straight
pride marchers you had thousands of
protesters 36 antipholus thugs get
arrested and charged a bunch of officers
assaulted so just right here just in
those numbers this exposes one of the
big lies of pride and the whole pride
movement the thesis the idea behind the
Pride Parade and the Pride Month is that
straight people are the oppressors and
heterosexuality is just the dominant and
oppressive culture and it's unfair and
it's discriminatory toward LGBTQ
alphabet people but that's not the case
what this parade shows this is actually
exactly the opposite the culture is
inclined in every way toward every other
sexual preference other than what we
would call traditional marriage 200
people trolling the concept of Pride
thousands and thousands of people
protesting the ones protesting the pride
and guess what the 200 straight Pride
pro-trump marchers they were not the
ones who were getting violent it was the
aunty Fay leftist thugs who were tells
you a lot about the culture and this is
why I love the straight pride mean it
just exposes hypocrisy it's kind of like
in Dave Chappelle's recent stand-up
special it's the same exposing hypocrisy
you know Chappelle no I don't want to
ruin it if you haven't seen the special
closure ears for 10 seconds Chapelle
does this joke and the joke is this he
says men shouldn't have an opinion about
abortion right woman's body woman's
choice men shouldn't have an opinion
however if a woman chooses not to get an
abortion and the man wants to the woman
to get in
Oshin then he should not have to pay to
support the kid his money his choice if
she can kill the baby he can at least
abandon the baby and then Chapelle has
this line it's it's one of the best
lines of the whole special he says and
if I'm wrong maybe we're wrong figure
that out for yourselves
he sets the whole thing up with the
logic of the left the logic of abortion
and then when he gets to the logical
conclusion of it which is well all right
you can kill it I can at least abandon
it even then I don't have to pay to
support it when when the audience
necessarily objects to that then he says
hmm maybe if I'm wrong maybe we're wrong
that is the same idea with the straight
Pride Parade the straight Pride Parade
is objectionable and ridiculous I think
the organizers would tell you that and
say yeah it's absurd to go out and
celebrate your sexual preferences oh
yeah the these certain things really
sexually titillate me let's hold a
parade for it doesn't make any sense
it's ridiculous that's objectionable but
if that's wrong maybe all pride parades
are wrong
figure that out for yourselves this is
it the protestors do have a point
when they're protesting the straight
Pride Parade but they only protest the
straight pride parade they don't protest
the gay pride parade or that this Pride
Parade and it's not even just gay pride
anymore it's straight it's skinny pride
fat pride [ __ ] pride [ __ ] marches all
it's all of this pride but if pride is
wrong for one group then pride is wrong
for the other groups it's the same thing
a few years ago a bunch of these white
pride racial politics types were putting
up signs on university campuses that
said it's okay to be white and of course
the that statement in itself is
completely unobjectionable who would
disagree with that statement but the
reason they put it up is to provoke the
response that it did provoke which is
people saying this is awful it's
terrible it's not okay to be white it's
bad to be white it's you say well hold
on a second if why is it okay to be one
race but not another race really what
they were provoked I mean I think we
would all agree white pride racial pride
movements are ridiculous and
objectionable but if white pride is
ridiculous and objectionable then so is
black pride then so is Hispanic pride
you know there's an organization on
university campuses they've recently had
to rename themselves because it was just
so egregious what they were called the
organizations called la raza
she literally means the race and it's to
celebrate Hispanic supremacy it's based
on an essay from the early 20th century
from a Mexican writer called la raza
cosmic ax about how much better
Hispanics are than every other race just
purely a racial supremacist tract and
that's what the organization's based on
there was that judge to judge that
President Trump attacks for being of
Mexican descent one of the defenses of
Trump attacking him is that the judge
was a member of a group called la raza
he actually was in a group the name of
which began with racial pride so yeah we
all agree I mean to ground your identity
to ground your pride to take great pride
in the color of your skin is ridiculous
but if it's ridiculous for one racial
group then it's ridiculous for all
racial groups you know these sort of
troll ish events are a great way to
handle this humor is a great way to
expose hypocrisy humor is a great way to
reveal reality and so I I encourage it
as long as we have pride parades then we
should have people making fun of pride
parades as long as we have pride parades
that purport to focus on sex when really
they're just about leftism then we
should have fake pride parades that
purport to focus on sex that really just
talked about defending America waving
the American flag and have transgender
people in the front row with the sign
that says pro-trump say it loud say it
proud we're straight we want to make
America great get used to it speaking of
hypocrisy and sexual pride we've got to
get to Hollywood just showing their
cards totally exposing themselves and
let me tell you Hollywood knows a thing
or two about exposing themselves if you
haven't followed the me2 story but a lot
of conservatives are upset about this
I actually think it's great you've got
some major Hollywood stars coming out
and openly calling for the blacklisting
of conservatives from the entertainment
industry we'll get to that in a second
but first we have got to talk about your
family history and ancestry.com
I love ancestry I'm been a fan of
ancestry for years and years you can
discover more about your relatives more
about your own story by combining an
ancestry DNA test with billions of
historical family records I I was using
ancestry before the DNA test even
existed then I took the DNA test and it
told me so much more about my family's
history where people move from how they
went from here in Italy to this place
over here and then they combined and
then half my family came from Northern
Europe ancestry DNA gives you so much
more than just the places you're from
ancestry connects you to the places in
the world where your story started using
precise Geographic detail and clear-cut
historical insights and so you can see
how your family moved how we all ended
up in America but what I love about it
is is the personal story because I
actually don't really care what regions
my family came from exactly what I care
about is combining it with ancestries
incredible genealogical resources so
that I can find out about my
great-grandfather John Knowles and my
great-grandfather Simon Knowles both of
whom fought at Bunker Hill then John was
killed there Simon went on to Valley
Forge with George Washington fought
throughout the rest of the American
Revolution you can go all the way back I
found out I've got not one before
ancestors on the Mayflower one of whom
was a pilgrim three of whom were
absolute derelicts one guy John
Billington I think his name is is was
the first guy executed for murder in the
new world tells you a little bit about
where I descend from you just learn
these incredible stories and you can go
back way way further to amplify your
results you can store a free trial on
ancestry build your family tree so your
answers ancestors rather become more
than just a name if combined DNA results
with over a hundred million family trees
and billions of records to give you more
insight into your genealogy and origins
it can tell an incredibly rich story it
can tell all about the events that
shaped your your ancestors it's just
absolutely incredible it's easy to get
started go to ancestor
komm slash podcast today for 20% off
that is 20% off your ancestry DNA get
ancestry.com slash podcast for 20% off
your ancestry DNA kit ancestry.com slash
podcast really really cool to check it
out
speaking of hypocrisy and sexual pride
we've got to get to Hollywood so
President Trump is holding a fundraiser
in Beverly Hills
The Hollywood left is not thrilled about
it as you might imagine so eric
mccormack who plays will on the show
willing grace a very left-wing show and
it was the first major gay show I guess
Ellen DeGeneres's show as well but Willa
grace was really a big moment for
homosexuality in the culture eric
mccormack tweets out quote hey hollywood
reporter kindly report on everyone
attending the Trump fundraiser so the
rest of us can be clear about who we
don't want to work with thanks now this
was news to me because Eric McCormack's
show the the reboot of Will & Grace just
got canceled a month ago cuz no one
liked it because it was screechie and
liberal and everyone hated it it was he
much worse even than the first go-around
so i didn't know that eric mccormack had
the chance to work with anybody right
now to begin with but i guess apparently
he thinks he does at least so he says
explicitly you need to publish the list
of people going to this fundraiser so
that we know who to blackball so that we
know who not to hire so we know who to
take their livelihoods away because they
are conservative you see they have
politics that half the country have and
we have politics that the other half the
country have so we are never going to
work with them again Debra Messing who
plays grace unwilling grace tweeted out
basically the same thing please print a
list of all attendees please the public
has a right to know first of all the
public does not have a right to know
absolutely does not have a right to know
there used to be something called
politeness and civility where you just
you wouldn't ask people their political
views or their religious views it
wouldn't insist on it on outing people
we have a secret ballot for a reason
we have a secret ballot so that
vindictive leftist bullies and McCarthy
i'ts like willing grace over here can't
pressure you into voting for their
candidate can't intimidate you and say
we'll take away your job and your money
if you don't vote the way that we want
to vote the comparisons are being made
to Joe McCarthy that's what they're
calling them McCarthy iit's and in some
ways they're behaving like McCarthy eyes
but it's important to realize here Will
& Grace or way worse than Joe McCarthy
at least Joe McCarthy the anti-communist
late Senator at least Joe McCarthy was
fighting America's enemies maybe wasn't
doing it in the most effective way but
at least he was going after communists
who had infiltrated the culture in the
government willing race are going after
people who support the US president will
and Grace are going after people who
wear hats that say make America great
again
that's categorically different Will and
Grace want to blacklist people who
support this country shows you have
perverse Hollywood is you know in 1999
the great director Elia Kazan won an
honorary Oscar and he won the Oscar for
his incredible career and Elia Kazan
became controversial in Hollywood
because he named names to the house on
American Activities Committee which was
trying to root out communists and people
conflate the house on American
Activities Committee Hugh ACK with Joe
McCarthy and McCarthyism but you have to
remember Joe McCarthy didn't have
anything to do with you ACK Joe McCarthy
was a senator not a member of the House
regardless it's a minor historical point
when Elia Kazan won his award because he
named names he named communists that he
knew who were actual communists working
in Hollywood a number of Hollywood stars
refused to stand up refused to applaud
Ian McKellen ed Harris major major stars
so how many of those Hollywood stars are
now going to shun Eric McCormack and
Debra Messing for their far worse
McCarthyism probably not very many you
know the silver lining of this incident
I think is it's Hollywood finally
admitting there is a blacklist
I think I know just about every
conservative in Hollywood and the reason
is it's a small community there just
aren't that many at least there aren't
that many who were kind of well-known
names there are a lot of especially
behind the camera there are a lot of
people who are gaffers who are working
on shows who are conservative and they
have to keep their heads down and keep
their mouth shut because they could lose
their jobs but this is certainly true
among actors and writers I mean just to
use drew drew as an example drew has
lost millions of dollars because he
openly outed himself as a conservative
you know it's another one of these lies
that this this is exposing is the idea
is that the culture is so conservative
that's the default position and to come
out as gay is so dangerous it's so
difficult it's so hard in Hollywood it's
exactly the opposite if you come out as
gay you'll you're probably gonna have an
easier time working here's an experiment
go out there and say hey I'm gay in
Hollywood see what happens to your
career and then go ahead and say hey I
support Donald Trump in Hollywood see
what happens to your career I guarantee
you if you come in and say you support
Donald Trump you will not work
I mean I've I've seen it real up-close
and for years and years Hollywood said
there's no blacklist what do you think
Clint is Clint Eastwood still works Jon
Voight still works there a couple of
Hollywood stars who have been open about
their conservative politics and they
work you say yeah of course these
superstars who were so big and so rich
and so famous
you can't possibly touch them they work
what about the stars whose names maybe
you know but maybe you've forgotten
because they stopped working or some
people who you've seen but you don't
quite remember their names it's those
guys who do get blacklisted I could name
all of them I can name a whole lot of
them right now but I won't do it because
if you say their names at it even
further compromises their chance of
working in Hollywood and for years they
said now it's just conservatives aren't
good at art they're not good at writing
they're not good at acting bs it's
because there is an active movement in
Hollywood to shut down conservatives and
you don't need to take my word for it
anymore Debra Messing and Eric McCormack
just
admitted it there being more open I
think it's great I want more of that
some people even conservatives fret they
say oh I just missed the time when
everyone was nice when people didn't use
these cut this kind of language when I
don't because back in those days you
know 10-15 years ago the left was just
hiding it they were hiding their bias in
the media hiding their bias in Hollywood
hiding the blacklist eyeing the
vindictive hot vindictiveness now
they're being open about it I want them
to be open I want it to be honest
light has a very good disinfectant
quality and I think maybe the the
hallmark of the Trump administration is
just opening things up in shining light
on the corruption in the federal
agencies in the mainstream media in the
press in Hollywood if Trump accomplished
nothing else if he doesn't build one
inch of wall which he might not build
one inch of new wall you would at least
get that advantage of opening up this
this really corrosive political
environment in this country and opening
it up to examination and opening it up
to a little bit of light you know if
you've got Hollywood going out and
saying we don't ever want to work with
conservatives we want to blackball them
that's basically the left doubling down
on the strategy of Hillary Clinton in
2016 when she said half the country is
deplorable and irredeemable strategy
didn't work very well for Democrats then
I don't think it's gonna work very well
if they keep that up in 2020 and the
Democrats are in a huge amount of
trouble in 2020 just look at their
frontrunner poor old Joe Biden Joe Biden
now before we get to his real flaw
before we get to what is actually going
to I think leave them very vulnerable in
2020 just get to the radicalism just
look at the radicalism which is not
their biggest problem but it is the sign
of a bigger problem Joe Biden who used
to be the moderate guy right good old
Joe working-class kid from Scranton that
guy is now endorsing the most radical
proposals on some of the most hot-button
issues so there was that awful shooting
that happened over the weekend
Joe Biden comes out he's not just
calling to limit
certain firearms to limit certain
magazines such that you can only get a
30-round magazine or a 10-round magazine
he is now calling for any any gun that
can hold more than one round at a time
to be banned Joe Biden is basically
saying every gun that isn't a derringer
needs to be banned from this country the
idea that we don't have elimination of
assault-type weapons magazines the can
can hold multiple bullets in them is
absolutely - it is no violation of the
Second Amendment it is it's just a bow
to the special interest of gun
manufacturers in an array it's got to
stop you want to talk about special
interests I think this is evidence
because it's such a nonsensical proposal
to limit guns to only having one bullet
I think this is evidence Joe Biden is
clearly in the hands of big derringer
you know that derringer Lobby has been
laying dormant for a very long time and
now those lobbyists have gone in and
they bought off Joe this is of course
mindless and of course it is a violation
of the second amendment to ban any gun
that can hold more than one round at a
time this would have been a violation of
the Second Amendment certainly with the
ratification of the Constitution and
every time since then we have always
permitted guns that hold more than one
round at a time that's virtually every
single gun at truly other than those
little tiny derringer is where you pull
it and it's got one bullet in it these
are not the sort of proposals that are
made by a political party that thinks it
has a good chance of winning the White
House that's really what it tells you
I'm not that worried that Joe Biden is
going to be able to ban you know every
kind of gun other than the derringers
what this shows you is the democrats
feel insecure they they feel unconfident
you know Biden is moving to the left
because his Democrat base is demanding
but Americans love guns recent surveys
on this even the so-called high-capacity
magazines that old you know 20 rounds 30
rounds 40 rounds whatever show that the
country is roughly split on the issue
it's about half and half want to keep
even large high-capacity magazines and
then the other half wants to limit it
ten or even fewer rounds per magazine
now imagine if you changed that survey
question to not high-capacity magazines
but magazines period any magazine at all
something tells me the overwhelming
majority of Americans would believe that
we should still be allowed to have
magazines for our guns future also-ran
bado or work is similarly calling for
the confiscation of guns and Bernie
Sanders is making even crazier proposals
than that well we'll get to what this
all is pointing toward because Joe
Biden's big vulnerability is not even
the radicalism the radicalism is a
symptom of what's going on the big
vulnerability runs much much deeper in
the Democratic Party and unless that
party changes course I think they're
gonna have to kiss 2020 goodbye we'll
get to all of that in a second but first
I've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube go on over to daily wire.com
check it out obviously you get me you
get the Android claim ensure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the amount wall
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag coming up on Thursday you get to
ask questions backstage coming up as
well most importantly you get the
leftist here's tumblr $9.99 a month but
when you get an annual membership for
just under a hundred bucks you get the
leftist to use tumblr and you certainly
need it you can't watch videos of the
straight Pride Parade without the
leftist tears tumblr go to daily wire ,
we'll be right back with a lot more
Biden wants to ban every gun virtually
every gun in the country other than the
single-shot derringer future also-ran
bado or Roarke is actually sort of
moderate in comparison beta or orc is
merely calling for the confiscation of
semi-automatic rifles yeah so I want to
be really clear that that's exactly what
we're going to do Americans will who own
ar-15s
ak-47s will have to sell them to the
government we're not going to allow them
to stay on our streets to show up in our
communities the ar-15 is the most
popular gun in America what beta or work
is saying is No thank you for giving me
the opportunity to clarify in moderator
my remarks I'm not going to moderate
them we're going to take away the most
popular guns in the country and we're
not going to do it based on any evidence
that it would lower deaths related to
guns in any significant way it wouldn't
if you wanted to reduce gun deaths you
would ban pistols and handguns rather
than any sort of rifle you were 22 times
as likely to be killed with a handgun as
you are with a rifle of any kind more
people are killed each year with hands
feet hammers and bats than they are with
rifles including the assault weapon
ar-15 semi-auto rifles so it's it's just
a temper tantrum it's really what he's
throwing a radical temper tantrum and
this is how he reacted to the recent
tragic shooting over the weekend his
reaction to gun deaths which just to
insert some facts into the discussion I
know you're not really supposed to do
that but if you look at gun deaths today
compared to 30 years ago we're moving in
the right direction now there's a spike
in for instance suicides that's very bad
that has to be taken care of but when
you're looking at gun homicides the
numbers are moving in the right
direction compared to say the early 90s
or the mid 90s so bado doesn't pay
attention to the facts he just goes on
TV calls to abolish the Second Amendment
and then his other big solution this is
how you
he's a super serious candidate really
confident totally ready to take back the
White House his big solution is to say
the f-word on CNN the rhetoric that
we've used the thoughts and prayers that
you just referred to it has done nothing
to stop the epidemic of gun violence to
protect our kids our families our fellow
Americans in public places at a Walmart
in El Paso where 22 were killed in
Sutherland Springs in a church one or
two a day all over this country a
hundred killed daily in the United
States of America we're averaging about
300 mass shootings a year no other
country comes close so yes this is
[ __ ] up and if we don't call it out
for what it is if we're not able to
speak clearly if we're not able to act
decisively then we will continue to have
this kind of bloodshed in America the
good news is fortunately people on CNN
or people be able to watch CNN so you
won't have to worry about the kids
seeing this other than people walking by
airports that's his reaction say the
f-word on CNN this is not the way that a
confident candidate speaks this is not
the way that a confident party speaks
this is the way that insecure people
speak you can even see it in comedy you
know
comedians go blue when they need a
crutch to rely on that's when they
really go blue you know they're kind of
Maday Lee show sort of left-wing comedy
way of doing things they'll play a clip
of a conservative and then he'll just
say something and then they won't be
able to make a joke about it so let's
say what the f what and then if the
conservative says a statement let's say
you know the sky is blue then the can
the liberal comedian version of that is
they'll cut back to him and he'll say
the sky is effing blue as though just
saying the f-word mean something it
doesn't people go blue they rely on that
crutch when they're not confident in
what they're actually saying if this is
true of comedians this is definitely
true of politicians obviously is it true
of politicians who go blue on TV even
more radical you'd think that
banning the most popular gun in America
banning all guns other than a derringer
you think that would be radical even
more radical four days ago Bernie
Sanders another top-tier candidate for
the Democrats in 2020 called for a meat
tax to battle climate change he wants to
tax meat he wants you to stop eating
meat or at least reduce the amount of
meat that you're eating not exactly the
most popular proposal this is not the
sort of proposal that candidates who
want to win a majority of Americans put
out Americans love meat Americans love
meat more than Americans love guns
there was a poll out couple years ago
confirmed Americans still love me 20% of
people responding to this poll said that
they intend to eat bacon every day of
their lives which probably will not last
very long if they're eating bacon every
single day but that's 20 more than 1 in
5 Americans
fully intends to eat bacon not even just
you know a cow but a pig apparently pigs
are like kind of smart you know they'll
eat bacon every day for the rest of
their lives and yet you've got a
top-tier Democratic candidate saying
well we need to tax meat we need less
meat in this country you know that thing
that you love we've got to do less of it
this radicalism shows that the Democrats
are in trouble and if Biden is the
nominee don't forget he is still the
front-runner I mean it's easy to forget
that because he's just a bumbling old
doofus but any and by the way he's not
just a doofus cuz he's old he's been a
doofus for his entire career if the
Democrats nominated by it will not be
the radicalism that gets him what it
will be is the hypocrisy what it will be
is that the Democrats are not offering
America anything that they don't already
have in Trump what it will be is the
lies you know Biden Biden's whole
campaign pitch is that he is more honest
and has a better character than
president Trump except he doesn't from
the very first moment of his
announcement video he talked about how
America needs to win her soul back and
Joe is going to restore the soul of
America and the character and the
honesty and the integrity but he doesn't
have better character than Trump I'm not
even saying that Trump is the greatest
character in the world he's a walking
Saint what I'm saying is Joe by
has no better character than the
president now we know that Joe Biden's
not more successful than Trump we know
he's not smarter than Trump we know he's
not more energetic than Trump again this
is saying nothing really about Trump
it's just pointing up Biden's flaws the
only pitch Biden can make is I'm more
honest I have greater integrity I've got
better character and the reality is that
he doesn't Joe Biden just got caught in
a big lie not even the kind of typical
lie that Joe Biden tells all the time
this was a lie about pinning medals on
Shirow Aksarben smen this is a lie an
elaborately constructed story where Joe
Biden says you mark my words all of my
honor as a Biden is going behind this
story it's a 100% true story and then it
turns out he completely made it up out
of Afghanistan in Iraq over 30 times I
pinned medals on silver stars on
soldiers up in the upper cone our valley
in the middle of a firestorm the poor
guys have gone through young Navy
captain Navy Navy up in the mountains
and the Cohen our Valley Afghanistan one
of his buddies got shot fell down a
ravine about 60 feet four-star general
asked me whether I'd go up into the fob
now everybody got concerned a vice
president going up in the middle of this
but there were we can lose a vice
president we can't lose many more of
these kids not a joke this guy climbed
down a ravine carried this guy up on his
back under fire and the general wanted
me to pin the Silver Star on him I got
up there and Stannis - God's truth my
word as a Biden he stood his attention I
went to pin him I said sir I don't want
the damn thing do not put it on me sir
please sir do not do that he died he
died God's honest truth my word as a
Biden except that my word as a Biden is
completely worthless because Joe Biden
is one of the most famous and prolific
liars in American politics even by the
standard of politicians all of whom lie
Joe Biden is one of the most egregious
offenders virtually
everything he said there is untrue
Washington Post found out Washington
Post wasn't even a conservative went
after him these were left-wing outlets
that went out and facts checked this
that when this alleged incident happened
Joe Biden was not the vice president he
was a senator when he made that visit
the service member he referred to was an
Army Specialist not a Navy captain and
Biden wasn't even the guy who pinned the
medal I think it was Obama who pin that
medal nothing about the story was true
completely fictional jumbling up a few
facts from totally different separate
events and then rewriting everything and
turning it into a work of fiction and
when Joe Biden was called out for it he
brushed it all off he said quote I don't
understand what they're talking about
but the central point is it was
absolutely accurate what I said which it
was not it was the opposite opposite of
absolutely accurate he gets caught in a
major lie and then he lies again to
defend it so the question is is he
losing his marbles this is just senility
creeping in or is he a pathological liar
he is losing his marbles doesn't look
good to people who already think he's
showing signs of mental decline which is
virtually everybody you know there have
been headlines a splinter had this
headline Joe Biden's mental decline is
impossible to ignore
Vanity Fair said Biden advisors worry
the gaffes are becoming a problem the
week says Joe Biden's age is a problem
and Trump is no excuse even the
Washington Post is Joe Biden too old so
he is losing his marbles and this
doesn't look good to those people I
actually don't think this is age related
I think this shows something we've known
for a while which is that Joe Biden has
absolutely no regard for the truth it's
not even like he's an intentional
deceiving fraudster liar sometimes I
guess he tells the truth but it's only
accidental he just simply doesn't care
he doesn't care whether what he's saying
is the truth or not and you you see this
very clearly in his response to it they
said mr. former Vice President Biden
everything you said was a lie he said
yeah but it was really it was true
obviously it was not now Biden has been
lire for his whole career in 1988 he had
to drop out of the presidential race
because he lied about his law school
transcripts and then he stole speeches
from an Irish politician and thought he
wouldn't get caught but it isn't even
just these sorts of lies you know the
self-aggrandizing lies that virtually
every politician tells he also tells
malicious and gratuitous lies about
other people you know the most
disturbing one and very few people
report on this Joe Biden lied about the
death of his wife and daughter tragic
death in a car accident in 1972 Biden's
wife and daughter were killed in a car
accident and the police concluded
definitively that the other driver
involved was not at fault he was
innocent he wasn't under the influence
of drugs or alcohol he was just an
accident it was a tragic accident the
incident weighed on this driver his name
is Curtis done until his death in 1999
and then almost immediately after that
driver died Joe Biden started baselessly
smearing him as a drunk driver he used
it in campaign speeches all the time he
said you know my wife and daughter were
killed by a guy who it was said he drank
his lunch
rather than ate his lunch another time
Joe Biden said oh you know he had pulled
over to a bar earlier in the day drunk
driver completely baseless he just about
about the most tragic event in one's
life even the Atlantic a very left-wing
outlet called him out for this in 2010
s-sit was so bizarre such a needless lie
if Democrats are running against
president Trump's alleged dishonesty and
character flaws which is what they're
doing it's hard to imagine a worse
candidate to go against him than Joe
Biden
you know if the Democrats nominated Liz
Warren at least she has something to
offer I mean that screeching awful voice
you know we might say okay alright if
you promise not to speak for four years
I'll vote for you just to stop that
yelling on the campaign trail she at
least didn't look she's very intelligent
is one thing really you could say about
Elizabeth Warren she's been raising heat
big wampum on the campaign trail from
donors you know she's got certain
characteristics that she brings to the
race even Bernie Sanders you know Bernie
who's a thousand years old - but he is a
hardline socialist he it's a hundred
year old hundred fifty year old failed
ideology that's wrought misery wherever
it's been tried but at least he's honest
at least he does seem to believe
something when when Bernie Sanders
believes in socialism he doesn't just go
wishy-washy he flies to the Soviet Union
for his honeymoon takes his shirt off
swilling vodka with the Rooskies and
sings communist folk songs I mean he
really goes all the way Joe Biden
doesn't have that he doesn't believe in
anything
he was in politics for 50 years and
accomplished nothing other than one good
crime bill in 1994 which he now has to
run against because the Democratic Party
hates law enforcement and wants to
spring criminals from all the jails so
he's got nothing substantive to run on
he's held every side of every issue he
was against taxpayer funding for
abortion before he was for taxpayer
funding of abortion he was for gun
rights before he was against gun rights
now he wants to get rid of every single
gun in the country in except for a
whimsical little one-shot 19th century
pistols all of those sort of things the
only thing he has to run on is I'm good
old Joe I might not be the sharpest tool
in the shed but gosh darn it you can
trust me I believe what I I'm an earnest
guy I'm sincere I of good character I've
got integrity he doesn't he doesn't and
the Democrats can't really run against
anything else at least not right now the
economy is doing great unemployment is
at record lows Manufacturing and
consumer confidence are really high we
have relative peace abroad they can't
run against those things even the trade
negotiations with which have been
extraordinarily dangerous have basically
been working we'll see what happens with
China that's still ongoing but with
Mexico it worked with the renegotiation
of NAFTA it worked so the only thing
they can run on or these kind of
mannered political questions you know
the way that Trump speaks the way that
he tweets
things he says and if Joe Biden is gonna
be the nominee if he's gonna run on
integrity and character he's got nothing
and Trump will win fifty seven states if
that is the case they've got to change
course if the Democrats want to have a
choice all right that's our show we've
got a lot more to get to but we'll have
to get to it tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show see them the Michael Nolt show
is produced by Rebecca dobkins director
Mike joiner executive producer Jeremy
bori our senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Dany D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and
makeup by Jesuit alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey everyone
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show what do the Jeffrey Epstein
case and brexit have in common a lot
they're both examples of the fight were
in which is a fight to preserve freedom
and to take down and entrench to lead
I'll show you what I mean
on the Andrew Clavin show I'm
complaining
[Music]